liberal Bill Maher giving the Democrats
another big dose of reality when it
comes to the left's indoctrination of
kids
we live in a prison yard in this country
which is everything is tribal and like
anything to do with schools or education
is something really the Democrats have
to answer for because they control it I
mean if you look at the Democratic
Convention it's like three quarters of
them are teachers my sister's a teacher
I'm a big defender of teachers but
what's going on in the schools it's
outrageous and somebody needs to answer
for it and just look at some of the
headlines in the last week Educators
demonizing white voices students cheated
out of scholarship opportunities all for
equity and teachers unions manipulate
contracts to push leftist ideas
all right um Greg since you know so much
about the schools and teachers I thought
I'd go to you first yes you know one
thing that the kids are not taught in
school is respect for authority and
kudos to to Bill Maher for his taking
this on yeah I don't know if it's about
the respect for authority thing I think
you know uh I think the point he's
making is that certain political parties
own certain areas of our culture and and
right now you're looking at one that is
falling apart and why is that and it's
because they're staking out the most
irrational positions on stuff like trans
surgery you don't have to take that
position right the most reasonable
position for for uh like you know gender
affirmation surgery is you shouldn't
perform it or any irreversible operation
on a healthy child who has no firmly
developed brain structure yet other than
that do what you want you want to wait
till you're an adult and I always say
this there's going to be a class action
suit between two groups of people it's
not going to be adults who did didn't
get transitioned and K when they were
kids it's adults who did so I think that
when you're in a situation in this
culture where that is considered
irrational that you can actually like
that our government actually believes
that you're a transphobe if you want to
get between a child a healthy child and
an activist with a scalpel we got
problems that's what he's get he's
getting at the fact that like for a
progressive like him to exist to survive
and to thrive there has to be standards
there has to be biology there has to be
math because if you take that all away
then there's no way to be able to tell
if you're making any progress at all so
instead you have a government that is
actually saying no kids should have the
right to have their genitals mutilated
before they even have a firmly
structured brain to understand it that's
crazy
you know Dana the six-year-old I think
it was last week who brought a gun to
school and then I think claimed that she
the the that they wanted to burn down
the burn the teacher as well I mean you
know they're talking about in the
schools it's not just in the inner
cities but the kids can't even survive
let alone learn yeah and in fact there
are many reports from teachers who were
leaving the profession because when they
came back from covid not all teachers
wanted to be home right so they come
back from covet school and the behavior
behavioral problems were so bad the
number of people in the teaching
profession who are leaving it's sort of
like on the police it's almost at that
same percentage-wise and that's that's
not sustainable and I think what Bill
Maher is trying to do is warn everybody
that if you want president DeSantis
you should allow all these schools to
continue to do this and get between a
parent and their child if you read the
New York Times big feature on this they
interviewed I think 50 different parents
spanning a full political spectrum and
to a person even the liberal ones were
like oh absolutely not you will tell me
if my child expresses a desire to change
their gender and they're eight years old
then yeah you're going to tell me about
it but I don't know what's going on I
mean it's been a long time since I've
been in school but I cannot I cannot
imagine this so parents are going
through a lot and they're looking to
people like Governor DeSantis who is
being very strong on this and not afraid
to take it on Jesse we had a show on
Friday where an undercover operation
went into a school district or several
in Ohio and caught teachers confessing
wow that they're teaching CRT and lying
to the media about it lying to the
parents about it saying they use code
words to get around it saying they
tricked the parents saying they're slow
walking it baby stepping next thing you
know CRT is everywhere
and you have to look out as a parent for
code words if they have a wellness
officer at the school they don't use
things like CRT if they say a class is
about belonging that's what you got to
look out for and a lot of these teachers
they're fighting a proxy war
against the parents they're poisoning
the children to get back at the parents
maybe the teachers have daddy issues
maybe they're uncomfortable in their own
skin but they hate the country they hate
the patriarchy and so they're just
trying to destroy these children to make
themselves feel better and it's actually
being a bully because they're going
after the kids
what would you do Jessica if you know
when Cleo goes to school I mean we know
the Biden Administration is all in on
this trans indoctrination I mean would
you be opposed to
them teaching your daughter and and
giving her you know the ability to
change without notifying you
absolutely not
first of all the
Administration is not in on trans
indoctrination no one I would not want
anyone giving my child puberty blockers
without consulting me I am not against
the idea of having conversation with
kids about gender fluidity which is one
of the main targets of these book bands
that are coming around now and that is
what it looks like when you live in
conversations about kids who identify as
they some of them not all of them but if
you want to live in Ron DeSantis Florida
and there are a lot of people who do
want to but the reason that it will not
be such a cakewalk as many Republicans
think instead of doing things like this
like Banning the teaching of AP
African-American history the Department
of Education said quote it teaches
students about activism
intersectionality and encourages ending
the war on black Trans queer and gender
and non-conforming and intersex people
I'm sorry what you want to cancel that's
the only APA class in Florida that's
getting canceled if you are a teacher in
Manatee County Florida you now are not
allowed to choose the books in your own
libraries it has to go through a media
literacy person or librarian for them to
choose there are teachers now who are
having to cover up or remove all of the
books that they have hand selected for
their classrooms because of this assault
by the government of Florida
I looked at the curriculum it's garbage
AP African-American history have you
seen the curriculum yeah come back the
next it was a joke and give me another
shot that stuff at the end there you
said that's total indoctrination all the
intersections by the way trans that's
the statement you don't think that black
Trans people exist or black queer people
exist I'm not a straw man or a straw
trans excuse me don't do that this is
serious no I'm actually being serious is
just because people do not want that
stuff it because it's age inappropriate
does not make them transphobic because
you're going there okay well
without a bug ban now
of Darkness a young adult novel about
two teens that have a relationship it's
now been 16 school districts are coming
for this book whatever I don't know
about the book yeah because good let's
let's book club it I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now